[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le soleil s'est levé très haut dans le
ciel de matin sans nuage
nous avions tous les deux mains tenant
par la main comme des enfants sans
manger
- de nos fils de loin du bruit nous
portons un merveilleux voyage
[Musique]
j'en ai moi même ensemble on a marché et
j'ai pensé dur et de belles journées
[Musique]
auray nous en voulons pas
on s'assure un nouveau divergent
cher de caresser vie s'incliner très bas
sur ton passage
en revanche frais d'entrée cheveux avec
le soleil pouces
pourtant encore 100
mais
quelle belle journée on a goûté le vin
nouveau et si dans la clairière
hé hé
on a eu en main chacun regarde de
travers
et puis on a
rentré la mousse et est si douce que
tous les deux bien trou nous avons fait
naufrage
[Musique]
jean
en me tenant apparemment par des enfants
sages
et prier dans la brière bancaire contre
menteur quel merveilleux voyage
avant de fermer les yeux
j'ai regardé et j'ai pensé à toi et la
belle journée il a fallu rentrer quitter
la forêt fini le beau voyage et chansons
s'arrêter nous l'étions piguet nous
rêvions de naufrage
et la prochaine fois je te promets nous
restons bien
je
mais et lebel jours d
elle approchait nombreuses de province
me
et le père
jour d'été
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]